pandémie oblige le 22ème sommet union
européenne chine s'est tenue hier par
visioconférence bruxelles et pékin se
sont expliqués sur leurs relations
difficiles à propos entre autres sur
l'ouverture du marché chinois aux
investissements étrangers à la gestion
de la crise du coronavirus ou encore le
renforcement de la mainmise de pékin sur
hong kong
précisions avec françois tisci et beach
les entretiens avec le premier ministre
a pu avec le président chi ont duré six
heures mais aucune déclaration commune
n'a été fait et les désaccords restent
nombreux concernant hong kong
si la chine rappelle que son action est
destinée à assurer sa sécurité et
s'oppose à toute ingérence étrangère
l'europe elle laisse planer la menace de
conséquences très négatives en cas
d'application de la loi de sécurité
imposées par pékin
la loi sur la sécurité nationale risque
de compromettre sérieusement le principe
un pays deux systèmes et le haut degré
d'autonomie de hong kong que nous
souhaitons voir se maintenir
nous avons donc également fait savoir
que la chine risque d'avoir des
conséquences très négatives si elle
continue à imposer cette joie
l'union européenne est en contact avec
nos partenaires du g7 à ce sujet et nous
avons fait connaître très clairement
notre position aux dirigeants chinois
aujourd'hui et les avons exhorté à
reconsidérer leur position
la loi sur la sécurité nationale à hong
kong est une affaire interne à la chine
nous sommes opposés à toute ingérence
étrangère dans cette affaire un contexte
de méfiance accrue par la crise du
coronavirus l'europe a ainsi pu mesurer
sa dépendance à l'égard de la chine et
accusent pékin de désinformation
pointant des cyberattaques précise
bruxelles est clair cela ne peut pas
être toléré
autre point de discussion et de
crispation les négociations entamées
depuis un an sur un accord sur la
protection des investissements qui
accorde aux entreprises européens un
accès au marché chinois mais surtout les
protègent de l'appétit des grands
groupes chinois subventionnés sur
celui-là van der leyen espère que les
conditions seront réunies pour conclure
cet accord avant la fin de l'année les
européens sont pour l'instant déçu
nous continuons d'observer des
déséquilibres dans nos relations
commerciales nous n'avons pas pu
progresser sur les différents points qui
avait été noté lors du dernier sommet et
en particulier par rapport à l'accès au
marché alors il faudra avancer sur ces
fonds c'est urgent et il faut également
un regain d'ambition chinoise sur
l'accord relatif aux investissements
un regain d'ambition demande également
par bruxelles à pékin dans la mise en
oeuvre de ses engagements pour le climat
alors que la chine représentant un quart
des émissions mondiales de gaz à effet
de serre a récemment construit de
nouvelles centrales au charbon